[Music]
so i want to play a quick little game
called celebrity confession let's do
this let's have some fun okay we know
that you like gotta stay fit but what is
your go-to cheat meal
i'm a big just cheese person i'm
vegetarian i flirt with veganism
occasionally but cheese is my vice it
had to be
just a giant plate of cheese
but pizza also yes and probably because
of the cheese and the carbs things that
are cheesy i love cheese i feel like you
can be best friends then okay what is a
habit or cork that drives your family or
your friends crazy
nothing i'm perfect
i got a few probably i'm not a good
driver
i don't do math
[Laughter]
i mean even simple math where people
around me be like what is wrong with you
when it comes to the country music
community who do you trust to watch your
kids
i'm sorry some dudes popped into my head
like no
oh tell me who tell me who's the no no
no no i like who's the yes
positive and good i was really lucky on
our last tour to be out with just
incredible ladies we had maddie and tay
out on the road with us and we had
runaway june and they loved on my kiddos
so much my boys would be in catering
isaiah would always be on somebody's lap
you know eating because he he knew he
knew what he was doing he's like pretty
girls
they were so good to them so i would
definitely trust any of those ladies to
look after the boys because they have
exactly okay i like that and just
wrapping things up who in the music
world is the best to party with
i don't know i don't think i can't
answer that question i don't party so i
don't know
[Music]